this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant
a problem-solving website that teaches
you to think like an engineer
space elevators are one of those
technologies that sci-fi nerds
like me obsess over they straddle the
line between
outlandish impossibility and genuine
engineering potential
it's a technology that could cross the
divide of science fiction
to science reality if we somehow
improved on existing technologies
it's the kind of thought experiment and
lofty engineering challenge
that could drive the development of
future technologies
necessity is the mother of invention
after all
before jumping into the technologies
that need to emerge
to facilitate space elevators let's
first explore what a space elevator
actually is a space elevator is exactly
that
a giant elevator shaft that we can climb
to reach space
eliminating our dependence on rocket
fuel to reach orbit and hopefully
in the process lower the cost of space
travel
this isn't your typical construction
that relies on the compressive strength
of a material to remain standing
our buildings are largely restricted in
height as a result of the compressive
strength of our building materials
the higher we build the more weight is
piled onto the foundations of the
building
we can counteract this by widening the
base of the construction
to spread the weight over a larger area
and then taper the building as it rises
to reduce the weight being added as we
add more floors
the most obvious examples of this are
the pyramids
but even the burj khalifa uses the same
principle
being widest at its base and gradually
narrowing to its seemingly impossible
height
we can build higher with current
materials if we widen the base but this
becomes uneconomic
pretty quickly as the base would take up
an unreasonable amount of space
so how would a space elevator solve this
problem
by counterbalancing the weight of the
structure by pulling
upwards we can do this thanks to
centrifugal force
imagine a tetherball swinging around a
pole at a certain angular velocity
the string will be held straight and
taut against the pole
because centrifugal force an apparent
force that appears in a rotating
reference frame
pulls outwards now the problem is
the whole point of feather ball is to
wrap the string around the pole
if the string can't rotate around the
center of spin it will simply wrap
itself around the pole
we are essentially trying to recreate
this dynamic but on an astronomical
scale
and to do that we have to work with the
earth's natural rotation
so our structure will need to be located
on the equator
let's imagine a base located in the
middle of the atlantic ocean
from here we're going to draw a straight
line out into space
for now this is just a line no structure
exists
but any structure that is constructed
will need to exist
along this line if it is not in sync
with earth's rotation the structure will
curve and break or
in some sort of cartoon world wrap
around the earth like the tetherball
example
our orbit will need to be circular
rather than elliptical
as an elliptical orbit would require a
tether
capable of constantly changing length
without breaking
we can find an orbit that will achieve
this with some simple algebra
to remain in a steady circular orbit we
need our centrifugal force
to equal the gravitational force
centrifugal force is defined by this
equation
where ms is the mass of the satellite
omega
is the angular velocity and r is the
distance
to the center of the earth while the
force due to gravity
is defined by this equation where g is
the gravitational constant
and mp is the mass of the planet the
mass of the satellite cancels out
while we manipulate the equations to get
a value for
r our orbital radius now we have an
equation with all the known values
which we can solve for by inputting the
values for earth
and we find a value of 42 168 kilometers
this is the distance from the center of
the planet so
we will be about 36 000 kilometers above
the surface of the planet
at the equator okay this gives us a
starting point for our construction
we are going to put some form of massive
satellite with a cable
into this orbit and begin the
construction process
building up from the planet is not an
option we need to build down
now this is where things get tricky if
we extend our tether
directly down to the earth we will shift
our center of mass
and disrupt our orbit to counter this
we're going to need to extend our tether
in both directions this keeps our center
of mass in geostationary orbit
and so maintains our circular orbit if
we place a counterweight on the far end
we don't have to have equal lengths of
tether on either side
to balance our load and this
counterweight could be a useful platform
for operations
so let's do that now something
interesting happens when we start to
extend our tethers out
since this is our neutral point where
gravitational force and centripetal
force
equal any material extending towards
earth
will experience more gravitational force
while any material extending away from
earth
will experience more centrifugal force
this creates tension in our tether
which will reach its maximum at our
neutral point at geostationary orbit
as everything below it is pulling
towards the earth and everything above
it
is pulling outwards towards space we can
calculate
the max tension in the cable with a
uniform cross section with this equation
where g is the gravitational constant m
is the mass of the earth
rho is the density of our material of
choice r
is the earth's radius and rg is the
radius of geostationary orbit
there is an explanation of how this was
derived in this paper
which you can find by matching the
reference number appearing on screen now
to the reference list in the description
all of these numbers are
fixed bar 1 the density of the material
we choose
if we choose to build this cable out of
steel with a density of 7900 kilograms
per meter cubed
our maximum tensile stress would be 382
gigapascals
that's 240 times the ultimate tensile
strength of steel
in other words steel can't do the job so
can we solve this problem steel is one
of the strongest materials we have
we certainly don't have a material 240
times stronger
but we do have less dense materials
which will reduce the tensile stress
we have to endure on top of this we
don't have to have a uniform
cross-section tether our tensile stress
approaches zero
at its end points but material at these
points
have the highest effect on our stress as
gravitational force
and centrifugal force increases as we
move further
from our geostationary orbit neutral
point
so it makes sense to minimize materials
at the endpoints
and maximize it where it's needed most
this will result in an improved design
called the tapered tower
so this brings us to a new question how
can we calculate the area needed
at any point along the tether our
previous paper has an answer once again
this is the equation they derived here
as
is the area of the tether we choose at
earth's surface
this starting value will largely depend
on design considerations
that we can't possibly know right now
but we are going to want to minimize it
because this right here
is an exponential function meaning our
width is going to increase
exponentially as we rise it is
imperative that we minimize
this value inside this bracket and we
only have two values we can control
in this equation the density which we
want to minimize
and the stress value which we are
designing for which here
is donated by t which we want to
maximize
normally we wouldn't use the maximum
stress the material can hold
as the design stress that leaves zero
margin for error
we should be designing in a safety
factor but for now
i'm just gonna go with it and say this
thing isn't going to be safe and i'm
designing it
right on the edge of braking so yeah
bear that in mind
remember that strength and density
material selection diagram from our last
video
let's refer to that again to pick a
couple of materials to analyze the
structure with
steel is cheap and well understood so
let's start there with a high-grade
high-strength alloy like 350 margin
steel
this steel has an ultimate tensile
strength that can range from 1.1
gigapascals to 2.4
with a density of 8200 kilograms per
meter cubed
this paper quotes a steel with an
ultimate tensile strength of 5
gigapascals and a density of 7900
kilograms per meter cubed
i don't know what aliens they got their
data from but this is beyond the realm
of reality
we will use steel but with more
realistic material properties
then we will pick some better existing
materials they wisely picked kevlar
which is a widely available high
strength fiber we could easily form into
a tether
we are going to throw two existing
materials into the mix too
titanium which we discovered in our last
video has
excellent specific strength qualities
and carbon fiber composites
which have even better specific strength
qualities and would be used today
if the sr-71 was redesigned using these
material properties
we can calculate the taper ratio which
will be the ratio of the area of the
tether
at the bottom of our elevator to the
area of the tether
at its widest at geostationary orbit i'm
going to assume a circular area
five millimeters in diameter at the base
by multiplying the cross-sectional area
at the bottom by the taper ratio we find
the cable's widest point
for steel this taper ratio is so huge
that our cable
at its widest point will be this number
whatever that is
for reference the width of the known
universe is 8.8 by 10 to the power of 26
meters wide
even dividing the diameter of this cable
by the width of the known universe
yields this number which i still can't
comprehend titanium
is marginally better now kevlar and
carbon fiber
are looking a lot better they will have
a circular diameter
of 80 meters and 170 meters respectively
still not quite feasible the amount of
material required to build something
like this
would outstrip any cost savings we could
possibly supply
and that's just assuming the fibers
could even be formed into this shape
without losing a significant portion of
their maximum tensile strength
which is a big assumption so i think
it's safe to say that right now
space elevators are possible in the
sense the physics of how they work is
based in reality
we just have to make a material capable
of making it feasible
especially when you consider we are
analyzing this at the ultimate tensile
strength
and in reality we should be using a
value below our yield strength as above
that value our material will begin
necking where the cross-sectional area
actually decreases
as the material elongates we aren't even
considering strain here
one future tech that a lot of people are
hyping up for future use in space
elevators
is carbon nanotubes whose strength is
off the charts
with some studies quoting ultimate
tensile stress values
as high as 130 gigapascals and a low
density of 1
300 kilograms per meter cubed at that
value
the taper ratio is just 1.6
if this material can be manufactured on
a massive scale
it would revolutionize life on earth but
we would still have to solve a huge
number of engineering challenges
eliminating vibrations and waves
propagating through the tether
is a huge challenge powering the climber
and dealing with the adverse weather of
the lower atmosphere and dodging space
debris in orbit
are all massive challenges before even
starting on the most fundamental problem
of all
manufacturing carbon nanotubes we will
explore these problems and potential
solutions
in future videos one on how carbon
nanotubes are made
why they are so strong and what needs to
happen to take them from the laboratory
to regular life and then we will revisit
this subject with a design investigation
for an actual space elevator using this
new
theoretical material during the research
of this video
i noticed several mistakes in the paper
i referenced
small mistakes that anyone could make
and easily overlook
i only noticed them because i applied
their methods myself
and noticed inconsistencies their
rounding was so aggressive that the
results were off by an
inconceivably large number thanks to
that exponential function in their
equation
and i noticed that their material
properties for steel was incorrect
because i recreated their calculations
for titanium
and noticed it was worse despite the
equation being entirely determined by
specific strength
this is the power of applying knowledge
yourself rather than being a passive
observer
you begin to understand things on a
fundamentally deeper level
and this is why i love brilliant and
believe they are the perfect complement
to my channel
i found myself struggling to remember
core parts of calculus
while following the derivations in the
paper and it's been years since i had to
integrate
anything so i have committed myself to
completing brilliance course on calculus
and advanced mathematics to brush up on
my math skills
which have dulled with the passage of
time i can complete this course
gradually in my spare time
keeping notes and using their mobile app
to steal spare time to progress
through the interactive courses this is
just one of many courses on brilliant
that will improve my ability to
understand the world around me
you can set a goal and improve yourself
too and then work at that goal a little
bit
every day if you are naturally curious
want to build your problem solving
skills
or need to develop confidence in your
analytical abilities
then get brilliant premium to learn
something new every day
brilliant's thought-provoking math
science and computer science content
helps guide you to mastery by taking
complex concepts
and breaking them up into bite-sized
understandable chunks
you'll start by having fun with
interactive explorations
and over time you'll be amazed at what
you can accomplish
as always thanks for watching and thank
you to all my patreon supporters
if you'd like to see more from me the
links to my twitter instagram discord
server and subreddit are below